thanks to everybody for coming my name
is steven naren
and i'm the director of the fortune off
video archive for holocaust testimonies
the fortunate video archive um which
began taping
testimonies in new haven back in 1979
contains more than 4
400 testimonies of survivors uh
witnesses and bystanders for the
holocaust it encompasses something like
12 000
hours of recorded material in over a
dozen different languages
recorded over the last 40 years in over
a dozen different countries
today in honor of black history month we
intend
to examine one of those testimonies in
the collection
the testimony of an african-american
veteran of the second world war
leon bass who entered the camps shortly
after liberation
i will be doing this with the help of
our speaker this afternoon anna dunsing
anna is a doctoral candidate in a joint
program for history and african-american
studies at yale university
her research writing and teaching
focuses on the united states and the
world
specializing in race and empire in
modern us history
african-american history transnational
and global history
and her dissertation titled strange
victory
cold war civil rights and the long
shadow of fascism
explores anti-fascist thought in action
in the 20th century black freedom
struggle
black radical theories of fascism in the
united states
and the role of the far right within
opposition to the civil rights
movement today anna will be speaking on
racism fascism and the jim crow military
as seen to the testimony of lee on bass
anna we're delighted you're here you
have the floor
uh thank you so much steven for the
invitation to give this talk
um thanks everybody who unfortunately
cannot see um
who has logged in to listen i realized
this morning
that it has been exactly one year to the
day
that i was last in new haven and and on
campus at yale
and um well i'm sorry we can all be
together in person
and while i recognize the gravity of the
impending
one-year milestone of this catastrophic
pandemic
i am nonetheless glad to be here with
you all and um
i also welcome anyone who's joining from
the greater you know beyond beyond new
haven
that is able able to join us in this
setting
so i'm going to try to speak for around
30 minutes and also show around 10
minutes of clips before opening it up to
questions and comments
um uh as as stephen naren said i've
built talk around the story
any experiences of an african-american
world war ii veteran named leon bass
whose oral history is housed in the
fortune off collection
and bass was among the soldiers who
participated in the liberation of broken
fold
which was just outside the german city
of weimar
and much of his testimony centers around
that unexpected and life-altering
act of eyewitness but he contextualizes
that experience within memories of
racial oppression in the united states
notably what it was like to serve in a
segregated army
relegated to an all-black labor unit
when he stepped through the gates
of buchenwald and after getting out of
the army army
bass became an educator and eventually a
high school principal in the
philadelphia area
and you can really see that expertise
that demeanor
the demeanor of a lifelong educator in
every aspect of his
testimony and his commanding presence
which you'll see is solemn but also
really affable
his storytelling his powerful and
accessible language
but most of all his steadfast commitment
to teach
um i'm really trying to honor all of
that in this talk
um and i'm going to draw on his
testimony but thread it together with a
with a bigger history
in order to tell a story about jim crow
america in the 1930s and 40s
about young soldiers navigating the
racism and other indignities of the jim
crow army
but more so i want to talk about how
americans responded to the rise
of fascism in europe responded to nazi
germany in particular
and responded to the escalating policies
of anti-semitism and violence under that
regime
and then toward the end of the talk
returning to the testimony of leon bass
i'll conclude by discussing
in brief how african americans responded
to the holocaust
and how it informed their understanding
of ongoing racial violence and white
supremacy in the united states
and also set the stakes uh for the
post-war black freedom struggle
and i do want to note that in this talk
i'm going to be showing one photograph
taken during the liberation of puken
ball that features the corpses of
victims
i'm also going to be showing two
political cartoons that depict
lynching the victims of lynching in
order to critique it
so in september
1933 mere months after the nazis had
come to power
a foreign correspondent for the
baltimore afro-american wrote an article
weighing in on the public debates
over the escalating rhetoric and racial
policies of the nazi dictatorship
for the fast for the past few months a
controversy on the jew in germany has
been raging he wrote
and it was inevitable that the negro in
america should be projected onto it
he was referencing debates in the paris
edition of the chicago tribune
that juxtaposed the situation of german
jews to those of african americans in
the jim crow
south the article meant to intervene in
this comparison
differentiating between the black
experience of racial oppression in the
united states
and the status of jews confronting in
his words the intensely narrow
nationalism and antiquated theories of
race
promoted by adolf hitler first of all
this journalist argued hitlerism
appeared to enforce a vastly different
social order than u.s
race hate nazi germany lacked the
anti-blackness and color lines that
crisscrossed every aspect of life
back home in his words the german jew
was also
largely indistinguished
indistinguishable from the so-called
aryan german
and black residents tourists and
students moved freely throughout germany
as they did throughout the rest of
europe in this way he argued
the persecution on the rise in germany
was not strictly about
race as he understood the term he noted
that the majority of germans being sent
to the newly constructed concentration
camps
were overwhelmingly socialists and
communists
comparison slips too quickly into
competition he remarked
and the jim crow racial regime was a
singular monstrosity
however he admitted there was no denying
that hitler's talk
sounds strikingly like the frothings of
a southern cracker
i want to hone in on this idea of
comparisons between jim crow and nazism
being inevitable
as well as the nature of the particular
comparisons or compare and contrast that
this journalist carried out in this very
early moment in the nasi regime
the black press had honed in on the
grammar of race and nation undergirding
fascism
while covering italy in the decade prior
hitler's rise to power only fueled the
comparative editorial fire
which not only noted shared affinities
and agendas
and made distinctions in policy ideology
and national context
but they also tracked cross currents of
admiration
imitation and direct exchange between
right-wing state and non-state actors
throughout the inner war era
african-american perspectives on fascism
and anti-fascist resistance in the 1930s
and 40s
are a crucial resource for us in the
ongoing contemporary debates
over fascist analogies and the fascist
potential of the united states
this historical archive is rich offering
a cumulative judgment that fascism
in power and europe an exclusionary
nationalistic
militant white race pride in the united
states
shared common roots enemies and
ambitions
for many white americans fascism
initially offered a kind of screen
upon which they could project their own
anxieties about us social economic and
race relations
depending on their politics then they
might celebrate or denounce relative
proximity
by contrast early african american
assessments of fascist parties
movements and regimes by both radical
intellectuals and in popular discourse
they this discourse functioned more like
an indictment and a warning
not only about what was happening abroad
but also the implications of those
developments for their own
lives african americans recognized the
centrality of
racial anti-semitism to nazi politics
well before their white counterparts
and they were quick to frame the fascist
embrace of race and nation as nothing
new
and indeed soon enough many black
activists intellectuals journalists and
everyday people
including the journalist i quoted at the
start of this talk
they arrived at the conclusion that
these comparisons and connections were
inevitable
because jim crow and fascism were
undeniable bedfellows
in turn they signaled alarm over what
they perceived
as dangerous new precedence of
racialized citizenship
social control state violence and
patriotic militarism
that would fundamentally transform the
world as they knew it
assessing the historical archive
african-american responses to european
fascism and the holocaust
are a mixture a broad mixture of moral
outrage
grassroots movement building political
opportunism
and anxious concern for the future for
humanity as a whole
for race conscious african americans
engaged in the growing black public
sphere of the 1930s
sensitivity to the race thinking and
imperial ambitions
undergirding fascist politics threaded
together these complex
and sometimes contradictory responses in
early 1936 the great poet
and major public figure langston hughes
expressed the sentiment that bound these
manifold viewpoints together when he
said
fascism is a new name for that kind of
terror the negro in america has always
faced
this kind of terrorism is extending more
and more to groups of people whose skins
are not black
fascism proved a flexible and highly
potent point of reference for african
americans
they approached fascism as an arsenal as
a powder keg
really of ideas cultures agendas and
tactics
rooted in racial colonial violence these
social and political forces to them were
already in circulation
already at work in their own communities
and in their own histories
yet newly fortified and fanatic in the
context of widespread
social conflict and global economic
collapse
the scholar michael rothberg describes
this work in the post-war era as
multi-directional memory
the idea that historical actors weren't
nearly comparing events and atrocities
in a competitive struggle for
recognition but rather as a way to
understand their worlds
and better articulate their own
experiences
of racial violence and state oppression
[Music]
black theories of and responses to
fascism in the 1930s and 40s
began from a place of relational
political engagement with europe
but argued that europe was not the sole
entry point for understanding and
combating fascism
this discourse tended to follow a
calculus of family resemblance
wary of fascism's capacity to travel and
adapt to diverse
national contexts
here i think is a good example of the
kind of comparative relational work that
i'm describing
a rhetorical move that was really common
across the inner war and wartime eras
on the left you can see an anonymous
woman
slain by the nazis with reference to the
warsaw ghetto
and on the right you see the body of
cleo wright who was lynched by a white
mob in sykeston missouri
in early 1942 after assaulting a white
woman
in her home miss lynching had garnered
international attention because it was
the first to occur
after the united states had entered the
war and because of this
added pressure of the global eye it was
also the first case of lynching taken up
by the u.s department of justice
the same day that this cartoon ran
however the black newspaper the
pittsburgh courier published another
compare and contrast piece by a white
liberal
that argued the difference between nazi
terror and jim crow persecution
was less in kind and more in terms of
historical
the historical direction of each social
order
so in in the words of this writer hitler
has crassly reversed the clock of
civilization
whereas we in america have been moving
slowly toward
more tolerance these debates
um in the black press in the black
public sphere were not preoccupied with
taxonomy but rather with the
vicissitudes of the worlds in which
african americans lived viewed against
the backdrop of
dictatorship total war and genocide in
europe
they show a complex combination of
sympathy and self-interest
they often sought to highlight american
hypocrisy and frame jim crow as a
backwards anti-democratic system
they aim to expose the very real models
that the italian fascists had
in the european scramble for africa or
the nazis had in u.s settler colonialism
and the jim crow south
in response to the passage of the
nuremberg laws in 1935 for instance
one journalist wondered what are jim
crow's
law's butt fascist laws likely unaware
of the extended efforts that nazi
lawyers had taken to survey u.s racial
legislation he ventured
it is difficult to believe that hitler
to save time
did not copy them directly from the
southern statutes
and from the unwritten laws of america
against negroes
in other moments this connective work
manifested as grassroots global
solidarity reformulating one group's
freedom struggle toward a more universal
politics
as was the case with the global black
lead mass movement that rose in response
to the italian invasion of ethiopia
in 1935. in other moments in public
discourse on fascism
african americans arrived at the idea
that there was a unique form of u.s
fascism born of racial slavery and its
many legacies
um this was often called our native
brand of
fascism and this brand came in forms as
varied as lynch mobs the clan
the police strike breaking union busting
and other attacks on labor
the south as you can imagine very often
took center stage but their assessments
also acknowledge the united states as a
whole
with its faulty democracy and
increasingly domineering presence on the
world stage
black anti-fascist discourse and
activism did show a growing concern over
nazi sympathizers and actual fascist
movements in the inner war united states
but the critique was much more often
centered on the insistence
centered on critiquing that insistence
on gradualism you heard in the article
i quoted the idea that the country was
moving slowly
toward more tolerance and the response
to that in light of what was happening
in europe in light of
everyone's feeling that things were
about to get much worse the response was
gradualism isn't enough
um and you can see a bit of that
attitude um in this cartoon which was
published two weeks
after uh kristallnacht and
this cartoon ran with the accompanying
editorial
colored america is also shocked but
there are some things that colored
america cannot understand about white
america's reaction
to the atrocities what they could not
understand was humanitarian support
and widespread condemnation without
self-reflection
on the united states's own history and
present realities
the article went on how could you be
shocked over ransacking
when the united states had quote robbed
indians of a whole continent
how could you be shocked over these
killings when 5 000 lynchings were on
record
how could you be shocked over racial
pollution laws when similar legislation
ordered american society
with the onset of war and especially
with the us
entrance into the conflict in late 1941
this argument gained a great deal of
political power
the united states was not yet a fascist
state within black anti-fascist analysis
but the pervasive presence of domestic
hitlerism
as they often called it put it in
complicit dynamic relationship
to the regimes of italy germany and
spain as well as those of european
colonial rule
this stance disputed the framing of the
conflict of world war
ii as one of democracy versus fascism
freedom versus tyranny good versus evil
it challenged the idea that the u.s
racial order was an acceptable system
emphasizing its hypocrisy
its vulgarity and its inhumanity
this argument found its clearest
expression in the double v campaign
which was first championed by the
pittsburgh courier and called for
victory over aggression slavery and
tyranny
both abroad and at home and in many
cases it was clear it was made clear
that this meant double victories against
fascism the american variety as well as
the european brand
as one writer put it and it's my sense
that at this point
it's really no longer about compare and
contrast
many many simply couldn't understand
fascism as an entirely foreign concept
the lines were far too murky and it
wasn't this
clear you know fascism was not this
clear opposite or sort of other of
american democracy but much more like a
doppelganger
and at times of course invocations of
hitlerism did function
as a simple shorthand or signifier or
insult
but the idea of a unique american
fascism had really taken hold
and it got to the heart of a lived
experience of racialized rightlessness
within a liberal democracy
and the scholars bill mullen and
christopher biles recently
um expressed this idea really well they
wrote
for people of color at various
historical moments
the experience of racialization within a
liberal democracy could have the valence
of fascism
that is to say while a fascist state and
a white supremacist democracy have very
different mechanisms of power
the experience of racialized
rightlessness within a liberal democracy
can make the distinction between it and
fascism
murky at the level of lived experience
for those racially cast aside outside of
liberal democracy's system of rights
the word fascism does not always conjure
up a distant and
alien social order the idea of an
incipient american fascism
as expressed through the double v
campaign raised the stakes of what would
happen
if they failed to succeed on both fronts
as one editorial from the chicago
defender put it in 1942
all of negro america is revolted at the
monstrous atrocities hitler is heaping
upon the jewish people we who are
negroes know that if hitler wins
we too will be the victims of slaughter
of even greater magnitude
if hitler wins the poll taxers of the
south who now use lynching as a weapon
of terror
will use it as a weapon of extermination
and as you can see from these images on
the screen
double v was also rooted in patriotism
and win the war gusto and it helped
inspire
and cohere the official logic of
patriotic anti-fascism
so central to the american war effort
wartime civil rights
efforts really marked a point of no
return for federal
policies federal support of racial
liberalism
that's the moment you really start to
see a sea change regarding
federal support of policies of racial
integration
and civil rights activism during the war
also pushed many white americans
to to really confront issues of racial
inequality in significant ways
giving rise to new standards of
tolerance and new terms
of acceptable language and behavior
and it's in this moment that leon bass
enlisted
bass was born and raised in philadelphia
he grew up in
predominantly uh black neighborhoods
went to mostly all black schools
and his parents who were former
sharecroppers from south carolina they
they kept him they seemed to have kept
him very sheltered
about the full force and structural
violence of
jim crow and racial violence in the
united states
however that all changed when he when he
joined up
20 years old by the time the second
world war had become a reality
no i was i and i finished school in 1943
and i was 18. and that's when i became
part of the military
and you how did you become part of the
military did you volunteer your draft
i i went out and i i volunteered and i
was to go out with the next group
and when i went down to the induction
center
institutional racism smacked me right in
the face
because the sergeant was there
and he told me to go one way
when i went through the door and he told
my white friends to go another way
because my country practices promulgated
promoted institutional racism and the
military was one of the largest
to do just that and so i went into an
all-black
unit say for the officers they were
white
but all of my comrades in arms at the
time were black
bass was promptly sent down south for
basic training
eight of the nine largest army training
camps were located in the south so this
was a common experience
for black gis that also meant the
majority of white officers overseeing
their training came
came from the south as well bass found
his time in basic training extremely
demeaning
and disaffecting not only for the daily
degradations of jim crow
but also for being relegated to a labor
unit
was your perception though that the
black troops generally though
fully understood the fact that while the
rhetoric of the war against nazi racism
and so forth
was fine uh in practice the country was
doing something entirely different yes
it was as though you were schizophrenic
our country had
was two personalities you know one way
we may make the wonderful pronouncements
you know we
we talk about our judeo-christian ethics
and we're going to make the world a
better place for democracy and all that
other
jazz but then when you cut down to the
real thing and you start seeing the way
they
operate you know things were not they
were not in consonants
and so i began to be an angry frustrated
young black soldier at this time i
wanted to get out of the army
i'll be very honest with you after my
experiences i really did not want to be
in this man's army and
especially after having to stand on a
bus
when there were no seats at the back
having to stand up for 100 miles
looking at empty seats yeah that didn't
endear me
to to my country um couldn't eat in a
restaurant
i had to go around the back and knock on
the door to get food and i'm in a
uniform
i and i saw pws prisoners of war
from germany being allowed to go in a
restaurant to sit down to eat and yet i
was not entitled to for that same
opportunity
bass shipped out for europe in october
1944
as part of the 183rd engineer combat
battalion
of the us third army soon they arrived
in belgium
fought in the battle of the bulge which
was the last major german offensive
campaign of the western front
and as laborers soldiers like bass were
on were really first on the front lines
and often last to leave
they built roads and bridges they loaded
munitions and supplies
they disabled land mines they
transported the wounded and they tended
to the dead
they crossed into germany in march of
1945
and by april they had reached the east
central german city
of weimar
just to the north in the hills above the
city of weimar
sat buchenwald the ss opened the camp in
1937
primarily for political prisoners but
they were soon joined by jews
roma jehovah's witnesses military
deserters prisoners of war and other
groups
between july 1937 and april 1945
it is estimated the ss imprisoned some
250
000 people there buchenwald was one of
44
000 camp schedules and incarceration
sites operated by nazi germany
and its allies across europe between
1933
and 1945 and the process
of camp liberation itself was a chaotic
affair
with u.s forces fast approaching the
germans had attempted to evacuate some
30 000 prisoners
roughly a third of whom they killed or
died in the process
in the meantime an underground
resistance network within the camp
stormed the watchtowers and seized
control in anticipation of the
approaching americans who arrived
that afternoon and found 21 000 people
there
in bass's words
we went to weimar and set up our bivouac
area and then
went immediately with an officer about
five of us
we were in the intelligence
reconnaissance section of our unit
and we went right to buchenwald
and that was the day that i was to
discover
what had really been going on in europe
under the nazis
because i walked through the gates
and i saw walking dead people
seriously walking dead people i am not a
doctor
i cannot assess things that accurately
but
and just looking at these people who
were skin and bone
and dressed in those pajama type
uniforms their heads clean shaved
and then filled with sores
due to malnutrition and here they were
coming towards us
making all kinds of guttural statements
and
using their own language and it was very
difficult for me to comprehend
what was going on i just looked at this
in amazement and and
i said to myself you know my god you
know
who are these people what have they done
what was their crime you know it's hard
for me to try to understand why anybody
could have been treated this way i don't
care what they had done
it just didn't grab me and i didn't have
any way of thinking
or putting a handle on it no frame of
reference i was only 20.
and here you can see the moment that
bass was just describing
um he only spent one day at buchenwald a
matter of hours
really but the experience fixed itself
permanently in the back of his mind
although for many years decades really
he never
spoke of it and he remained stationed in
germany long enough
to watch massive swastikas demolished
off of government buildings
in the city of nuremberg before he was
shipped to the philippines where he
served for another
eight months
now ve day in early may 1945
was jubilant but as of may 1945
color lines snaked across every aspect
of american life
white mobs vigilante groups and a
numeral
innumerable iterations of local state
and federal
officials police these lines as they saw
fit
jim crow lawmakers vowed to defend the
social and political order at whatever
cost even blood banks remain segregated
a holdout of popular racial science so
egregious
so glaringly parallel to nazi race law
that it became one of the most
heated civil rights issues of the war
years
articles and man on the street
interviews published in the black press
in the immediate wake of ve day indicate
that germany's total surrender prompted
questions
about whether fascism had really been
defeated whether it could ever be
defeated within western capitalist
societies
and about whether white americans were
poised to learn anything
from fascisms fascism's reign and
apparent ruin as one factory worker told
her interviewer
if the whites haven't learned by now i
guess they never will
and here you can see two political
cartoons from the summer of
1945 grappling with um
clear obvious signs of
anti-blackness and racism continuing
as the war came to a close um
and as the war came to a close and
really in in the months that followed
racial violence did surge throughout the
united states
right mobs of white vigilantes were
targeting
returning black veterans you saw this
deliberate stripping away of wartime
gains through a
southern mobilization in defense of jim
crow
in the summer of 1945 in congress
lawmakers staged fierce campaigns on the
floor
of the senate arguing against fair
employment legislation and fought
viciously against widely supported
efforts to eliminate the poll tax
and pass federal anti-lynching
legislation
there's one really remarkable article
from that summer in which a black
columnist
named marjorie mckenzie observed that
all of this racist
and really explicitly racist and
explicitly anti-semitic
filibustering that was happening at the
capitol garnered new meaning
when you recognize that just a
block away mere steps away at the
library of congress they had opened an
exhibit
of mural-sized atrocity photos these are
scenes from
from concentration camp liberation
and thinking about that juxtaposition
mckenzie wrote
it has said it has been said that is a
good thing for americans to see the
horrors of the german concentration
camps
because seeing them will make us resolve
never to allow anything like that to
happen here
but mackenzie doubted such an assertion
the military collapse of fascism is
going to leave the world a heritage of
fascists without labels
she wrote to defeat the organized
strength of a system of government
without destroying the ideology upon
which it is based
is dangerous and her argument
really returns to this this theme i
already mentioned her argument came down
to the murkiness
of you know the lack of demarcation line
the instability of the demarcation line
and the vigilance that would be required
to determine
where one form of politics began and
and one or one where one ended and one
began right and making that
determination before it was too late
and for some claims of american fascism
a kind of unique form of american
fascist and they were largely rhetorical
they were a provocative way to tie
foreign affairs to domestic issues and
draw attention to the civil rights cause
for others however the threat of u.s
fascism was plausible
and rather urgent and for many i think
it was some combination
of those two feelings uh some strategy
and some
dread and either way they were rooted in
understanding that white americans
refused to actually interrogate their
history
their complicity their insistence on
reform
rather than reconstruction an early
post-war commentary in the black press
that focused on the afterlife of fascism
the idea that
hitler had been defeated but his ideas
had not
the realities and residue of those ideas
they they argued they were still
palpable in american life
and they included racial chauvinism
and nativist sensibility exclusionary
nationalism defined through legal claims
to whiteness
lost cause nostalgia and fantasies of
white victimhood
a militant and deputized citizenry
the mass caging of internal and external
enemies and reservations
ghettos and detention centers and
prisons
and after 1945 reckoning with all of
this african americans called for
justice they called for reflection
but really clearly they called for
vigilance for they recognized
that there was a danger that fascism was
still pending
in a world that had already shown that
they it wasn't going to come to terms
with with what it had just
done and for bass it would take him some
time
to to to put these connections together
um
upon his return home sort of set to make
a life for himself he started a family
he got his phd he built his career and
he became involved with the civil rights
movement
uh the assassination of martin luther
king in 1968 had a profound
impact on him and in his testimony he
describes the heartache and horror
that he felt in the wake of that event
this was a personal grief and
disillusionment for him personally but
it was something he saw reflected black
back
tenfold in the young black and brown
students
at the high school where he served as
principal so it was around this time
sort of late 60s right around 1970 in
particular
that he started to think about lukenbold
again
and one day i came to a classroom
and in that classroom there was a lady
and she was trying to talk to the young
men who were not listening to her
you know they're doing everything but
listening and i stood the door and i
began to realize that she was a survivor
and she had survived one of the worst
camps she had survived auschwitz
and she was here today on this
particular day to share her experience
her pain
if you will and these young men were not
listening
they had their own pain you know and i
understood that you know the pain of
rejection the pain i'm not giving
being given the kind of recognition you
deserve i understood all of that i had
been through there and i knew
their pain but i also knew her pain
and so i had to say to them hold it
fellas cool it
listen what she says is true i was there
and so they got quiet for a while and
once she started
telling her account of what happened at
auschwitz
they really listened and she told him
how she lost her grandmother grandfather
our parents brothers sisters cousins all
those near and dear who had come into
that camp
all of them had gone to the gas chambers
and had ended up in the ovens
and of her family she was the only one
that came out of there
and they listened she shared with them
so much
and they asked her questions which made
me know that she
had to reach them they came up and
looked at the numbers tattooed on her
arm and
they thanked her and they did something
i
hadn't been done in a long while they
left that room in silence
and of course she turned to me and of
course tears were coming down her face
and
she thanked me for my intervention and
wanted to know more about my experience
at book involved
and i began to remember
bassa's own experiences with the
exclusionary racial order
of the united states and in later years
his awareness of the inequalities that
shaped the world
of his students coming of age in the
late 60s
all this became the lens through which
he came to process what he saw at
buchenwald
he realized that the camp was not a
singular place
in his words but rather evinced a
culmination to white supremacy
the face of evil he called it racism
anti-semitism bigotry prejudice
and all manner of hatred bass concluded
that jim crow and fascism
did stem from the same roots and like
many before him he felt
the problem was that the united states
had largely failed in the necessary
project of probing those roots those
that
cut deep across europe and its colonies
as well as those that stretched in
hardened networks
through its own rich and bloody soil
and look what it did to us racism has
just about split us so many different
ways to we can't
live in harmony with one another
suspicious
all of this i discovered uh
as an adult and i didn't get it when i
was young when i should have had it
because people didn't want to deal with
it was an ugly side of our history
and ugly things we want to push under
the rug we don't want to deal with it
and i'm saying to people today you must
face it you can't laundry and sanitize
our history
you must take history with his beauty
and you must take it with its
degradation
you've got to deal with it for us to be
whole human beings and
and to make a difference and it's
especially true with young people
and so i go around telling my story and
of course i you know i get the
people saying leon what do you deal with
this this is this is not a black
problem why i said hey it's not a black
problem it's not a white problem
it's a human problem and we've got to
face it
and as dr king says injustice anywhere
is the loss of justice everywhere you
see where's
that effect and it's true what affects
you affects me
your pain has to be my pain my pain has
to be your pain
and i must somehow convey that to the
young people
that i come to it's my commitment
and somebody says uh you why do you deal
with that mess you know i
i said i'm sorry i know it's been 40
something years
but that doesn't make it go away it only
makes us
become more aware that we today have to
do something that
to stop that which created
the final solution and that something
is racism really racism is at the root
of all of this
under that umbrella comes bigotry and
prejudice and discrimination
unemployment people who are unemployable
large institutions filled with those who
are drug addicts and those who are
criminals all because somehow we have
come to grips with that institutional
call racism
and we have to because we see the
ultimate of racism which was what i saw
at buchenwall
and so what do we do do we as educators
and
and i use it in the broadest sense
because we're all teachers of the young
in our way of life
do we convey to them the best
that we can be or do we give them the
worst side that we have
do we promote racism through our
apathy when we hear and see things we
say nothing
because we don't want to jeopardize that
which is important to us our investment
in a job
our investment among friends we don't
want to disturb our families so
no matter what people say or do just
leave it alone sweep it under the rug
and somehow it'll go away but the
skinheads are with us
the clan is with us it may be dressed in
brooks brothers suit with attached cases
they may be in doctors they may be
lawyers they may be
the guy who drives the bus but they're
still with us
and just to conclude uh the steady
advance and nationwide embrace of the
civil rights movement in the 1950s and
60s
did confirm that the fascistic
filibustering of mississippi senators
had been their swan song after all
these decades saw a substantial decline
in the excessive mob rule and public
expressions of racism public acts of
racism and white supremacy so pervasive
in the age before
yet as bass puts so well many of the
currents
of of white supremacy but also the vast
structures of race and class inequality
in the united states are still
with us and a significant part of the
problem
are americans who choose every day to
buy into a myth
that a myth of the united states that
for many people does not exist
white people were and are astounded by
the holocaust in germany
wrote james baldwin in 1962 they did not
know that they could act that way
but i very much doubt whether black
people were astounded at least
in the same way in signaling a heritage
of fascists without labels in the united
states
african-american voices in the 1930s and
40s laid the groundwork for a long-term
challenge to the patriotic anti-fascism
and narrow myths of
progress which whitewashed national
memory in the post-war united states
they helped to forge an anti-racist
anti-fascist counter-heritage and
radical organizing tradition
with tremendous coalition-building
possibilities
not only across the civil rights era and
the age of black power
but also up into our present moment
thank you
thank you anna thank you um
we have a little bit of time for uh
questions
so if anyone uh would like to ask
anna question you can use the q a button
or the chat fueled both of those we do
have one
question already uh
and this is a question about the
economic system
and um the question is
is capitalism to fascism as socialism is
to communism is our
economic system one reason it is so
difficult for us to recognize who we are
it's a big question but
to the heart of it is our economic is is
our economic system
or economics somehow tied up with why we
can't
um we can't seem to come to terms with
uh
racial inequality to a very uh do a very
big question i'll i i will offer
a brief answer which is yes right and
and learning from the you know the
the you know black radical theorists who
were writing explicitly about this
um over 100 years ago right they would
say that the
the entire formation of of the american
economic system was on the basis of
chattel slavery and
and plantation economics right so they
would say the two are entirely
caught up together and anti-blackness
and racial formation was part of the
maintenance
of capital and was the sort of
justification for capitalist
accumulation and
expansion and extraction of goods and
colonies right so
the simple answer is yes um i think i
think they are entirely tied up together
thanks all right gil has a question here
fairly long um i'm i'm gonna go ahead
and read it because i think it's worth
reading
uh in its entirety um so gil found it
fascinating that you
highlight how black american
commentators understood european fascism
as centered on racism
rather than about authoritarian forms of
government as
it has been recently discussed here in
the u.s and he thinks that's an
extremely important perspective you
talk mainly about perceptions of
resemblance between european fascism and
the u.s
but i wonder if you can talk a bit about
the history of actual legal relationship
and influence just two examples to
prompt discussion would be james
whitman's
book hitler's american model and
and the relationship between uh nazi
race policy and jim crow you
talked a little bit about that in your
talk um and there's another
uh i think uh robenbach i believe has an
article about
how african-american intellectuals tried
to draw on the new postwar concept of
genocide
coined by raphael lemkin during the
holocaust
um after the holocaust to to fight
lynching in the south
and how it became intertwined with uh
with continuing your point
soviet depictions of the us as a fascist
state
yeah but those are yeah those are great
questions and definitely like the
undercurrents of this talk and things
that i sort of had to cut
in order to make this the fit the time
so um
first of all right that's a little bit
what i was trying to get at right that
as early as like
literally before the march on rome in
1922
um the black press is sort of
having debates like are the fascists
like klansmen and oftentimes they would
say
no because the clans the fascists are a
little more dignified
right they're sort of you know but but
those there was this feeling early on
that was about
you know this compare and contrast that
was pretty abstract that
was about you know parallels
similarities
echoes but also from the beginning they
were
looking at moments of direct exchange
and
alliances right so it's it was something
like just a few months after the
fascists in italy came to power
uh a leader in the ku klux klan
announced that he wanted to forge an
alliance with them in order to bring
the clan struggle for white supremacy to
europe right so you so you do have
direct admiration borrowing and exchange
um you also of course have massive
routes of of
interaction in the field of eugenics um
you know i think there's a very famous
comment where some american eugenicists
said that the nazis are beating us at
our own game
and of course you have the research that
that james whitman's book
um put so well right that that the
the the nazi government did study
the kind of elaborate systems of
american race law to try to figure out
what did and did not work and we're
actually quite perturbed i mean
recognize that
um many things wouldn't work in the
context of nazi germany but learned a
lot specifically about
um anti and sort of racial
terms of citizenship so so the nazis
also learned a lot
from the johnson reed act the very
restrictive immigration law passed in
the united states in 1924
um and also miscegenation laws right um
so so you do have these moments of
direct exchange which i think are also
fascinating because the archive is just
full of people tracking the parallels on
both levels right on the kind of more
abstract
level of parallel agendas and on actual
routes of exchange and really quickly to
your second question i mean that's
that to me is is such a key component
sort of in the
in the wave of sort of in the immediate
postwar moment there are actually three
different petitions submitted by
african-americans
to the u.n um on be on behalf this is
the first one
by a group called the national negro
congress in 1946
um that was calling for an end to
discrimination the second one by the
naacp in 1947
to the kind of coming together human
rights
convention and then the last one was in
1951 by the civil rights congress
specifically demanding the united states
be charged with genocide
and i think everyone should read that
petition we charge genocide it's
extensive it's 240 pages
but but it shows a very keen
really brilliant really sharp but no
less provocative
interpretation of the of the actual
legal
crime of genocide actually raphael
lemkin
disapproved of the petition but i think
that story really you have to understand
it in the context of the cold war
and even to see how much the amer the
american public
widely praised um the 40 the 46 and 47
petitions
but by 1951 condemned it
across the board right and it's
significant that that the national negro
congress in 1946
and the civil rights congress in 1951
were both directly affiliated with
the communist party right and that is
the kind of other undercurrent of this
whole talk
um were you know that the the we're
talking about the heyday
of radical interracial trade unionism
and communist organizing in the united
states but again what i think is so
fascinating about this archive is just
explodes
past that pretty quickly and i think
what's really significant is after the
hitler stalin pact
you know which was such a huge blow to
the left the language of anti-fascism
lived on right it really continued to be
a popular vernacular
um related to but also unmoored from
the kind of political and ideological
commitments of of
the communist international yeah great
question
yeah great great answer so um we just
have
a couple more questions and then um i
think we'll
we'll start to wrap things up this is
also another
big question but i think the talk uh
it's clear that the talk will bring a
question like this up
um it seems as there as if there should
be great empathy and understanding
between
the american jewish community and the
african-american community
um how would you explain though then
that there is such
times of moments of such animosity and
conflict between these two groups
um in past and in the present
yeah no that's that's a great question
and i think um
we can we go over can we go i don't want
can we go past
sure okay i don't yeah i don't i don't
want to have to like rush these things
because it seems very serious um
so i mean i think that's actually reason
enough to just go and sit and watch
leon bass's full testimony
because what exists underneath the
surface of his whole
um his whole oral history is that
the interview was conducted in 1988
which i think was this particularly
heated moment
of tension and um you know eventually
with the crown heights riot sort of
outright
um violent clashing between black
americans and jewish americans right
and um i mean i think
my interest in this archive and all of
these calls for
solidarity and all these calls for sort
of building
a movement and alliance in the inner war
period was
in was sort of in pursuit of a larger
story than what i had heard
um for many years of my education right
above these tensions of
the pervasiveness of um
anti-black racism amongst jews and
anti-semitism amongst
african-americans sometimes in the
archive you do find
um uh people writing editorials
in the black press right saying like we
have to stop this right sort of
condemning
um the explicit anti-semitism of groups
right and a lot of that was sort of
rooted in local
i think either sort of in the case
of of particular cities like new york
um local issues local tensions
um but i think
an example i really like so that book i
mentioned this is someone else
asked about book recommendations and one
of the ones i'll mention which i think
has such a beautiful example to think
about this
um michael rothburgh
with this great book called
multi-directional memory it's his
attempt to try to understand how it's
sort of less
looking at holocaust memory
decolonization and civil rights
movements and events that happened at
the same time
what are the moments of collaboration
and cross-referencing rather than
competition
and his explanation for at least in the
united states why the competition um
happens is he uses the example he was
writing a book when they were getting
ready to open the national
museum of african-american history on
the national mall a lot of people were
struck by the sort of symbol that
um that museum was taking up the literal
last plot right of the national mall
um and he said you know for for
racialized groups in the united states
for minorities in the united states for
groups who are subject to
racial persecution and prejudice in the
united states there's often a feeling
that there is a limit
to the amount of tension and the amount
of recognition that they can get
right so there's like a competition
competition allah real estate for who
can be represented who can be protective
um who can receive dignity um and his
argument is essentially right
that that justice and solidarity and the
pursuit of
human dignity should not be like real
estate right that it should be
rooted in um collaboration so i think
my research i've just been over the
years been so struck by how many
other um conversations were happening
but i think it is significant and it's
important to recognize um the violence
and contention as well
and i think someone else had a book i
think another if you want to like what
was
do you want to get the specific book
recommendation so funny i'm like
surrounded by the books
i used to write this talk i mean i think
to me like an amazing
classic place to start truly the book
that got me into all of this
is um glenda gilmore uh yale professor
glenda gilmour's defying dixie
um not only is it just um an
incredible extensive history she's also
just such a beautiful
writer and a brilliant scholar um so i
really strongly recommend this
and then um two more
that i just have all around me um one
is um susan pennybaker's from scottsboro
to munich
um which looks more at the black
diaspora and concentrates in great
britain
and then finally this just came out and
this was the book i quoted from
the u.s anti-fascism reader it's a
really amazing
um very recent collection of
all sorts of different political
perspectives all sorts of different
arguments all sorts of different
assessments
um from the 1920s up through the present
great um i dropped a couple of links
to to those titles
[Music]
as well in the chat um but you're
welcome to get in touch uh with me my
emails on the
website and i can i can provide you with
more information about those readings if
you'd like um
if there aren't any other questions then
uh i'd like to extend my thanks again to
anna for
some really enlightening presentation
and
thank you to everyone who came today and
we'll see you
next time thank you all so much and
you're welcome to send me an email
if you want to if you have questions or
want to chat